Are you sitting comfortably?
We know a good chair is hard to find.
Maybe you’re watching this on your phone
while you lie in bed, or maybe you’re watching
it at your desk, sitting in an office chair.
Maybe you’re even watching it while you’re
in the bathroom; it’s fine, we’re not
here to judge.
For our money, you just can’t beat a nice,
classic wooden chair, with soft leather upholstery.
Call us old-fashioned, but some things just
never go out of style.
Take a chair like SCP-1609, for example.
This fine piece of mahogany was once a chair
that simply couldn’t be beat in its quest
to bring its users a little dose of comfort
and refinement in their daily life.
Tell us, have you ever been on your feet all
day, just walking and walking and walking,
and at a certain point, you’re just begging
for a nice, comfy chair that’ll let you
take the weight off your feet for a little
while?
You would have been SCP-1609’s favorite
kind of person.
After all, it was the only chair that literally
sought out weary travelers, and even did you
the courtesy of tucking itself in.
That’s not a metaphor, either.
SCP-1609 could literally teleport to nearby
people who needed to sit down and didn’t
have a chair to fulfill that desire.
It was nothing but a nice, helpful anomaly
that wanted to help people rest when they
needed it most.
The more observant members of you may have
noticed that we’ve been using the past tense
so far.
That’s because, while SCP-1609 is still
an active anomaly, it isn’t a chair anymore
- and this transformation wasn’t something
that SCP-1609 planned, anticipated, or even
wanted.
The story of 1609’s transformation even
strikes to the core of one of the Foundation’s
oldest and most bitterly held rivalries with
another group of interest.
It’s the tale of how a helpful piece of
anomalous furniture became a paranoid killer.
But first, we need to talk about containment
procedures.
Like a word you see so often that it starts
to lose meaning, containment and specific
containment procedures are concepts so integral
to the very existence of the SCP Foundation
that it’s easy to overlook or forget about
them.
They’re one of the three core pillars of
the Foundation’s mission statement - Secure,
Contain, Protect.
Because of the centrality of containment to
the Foundation’s core principles, one of
the most valuable roles on the SCP Foundation
payroll is that of the Containment Specialist:
A vast team of experts who work with researchers
to figure out the best way to keep every anomaly
contained, based on their unique abilities
and attributes.
They’re zookeepers, archivists, guards,
security and intelligence experts, magicians,
practitioners of ritual, scientists, and so
much more.
In short, they’re anything they need to
be in order to adapt to the ever-evolving
containment needs of the anomalies they keep
under lock and key.
And containment isn’t easy.
Aside from the rare Safe-class SCPs, which
require incredibly minimal containment resources,
the containment of most SCPs extracts some
kind of cost, whether that be financial, time,
effort, or in some particularly dark cases,
human life.
Some SCPs, like SCP-974 and SCP-2845, require
the sacrifice of human children to prevent
worse fates befalling many others.
Other SCPs, like the infamous SCP-231, require
the Foundation to do horrifying things to
the SCP itself to prevent it from manifesting
some even more horrifying anomalous traits.
And a third but equally inconvenient kind
of SCP, like SCP-682 and SCP-076, require
huge numbers of heavily armed guards with
powerful weapons to keep their deadly prisoners
locked away, often at massive risk to their
own lives.
Containment isn’t easy, but it’s ultimately
the very thing that makes the SCP Foundation
the organization it is.
If they were instead on a quest to kill and
destroy every anomaly they could get their
hands on, then, they’d be the Global Occult
Coalition - the UN’s answer to the SCP Foundation
that prefers to seek, disable, and destroy
rather than Secure, Contain, and Protect.
It’s the primary characteristic that differentiates
these two titans of the anomalous world who
regularly come to blows, and right at the
heart of that difference is SCP-1609.
As we mentioned earlier, SCP-1609 went through
a transformation that changed everything,
but the SCP Foundation never actually knew
about the anomaly prior to that transformation
taking place.
It first came to their attention when it literally
manifested within a containment cell in Storage
Site-08, making the rare move of willingly
submitting itself to Foundation containment.
But what showed up in that cell certainly
wasn’t a chair.
When 1609 appeared all it looked like was
a pile of trash - specifically, splinters,
wood chippings, furniture nails, and scraps
of bleached leather and fabric.
Anything that suddenly infiltrates a secure
Foundation containment site is a cause for
concern, even a bunch of wood scraps, so the
Site Director sent in an armed guard to investigate
the mysterious pile of debris.
Researchers watching over a surveillance feed
were surprised when the guard suddenly entered
a state of heightened distress.
He fell to his knees, coughing and spluttering
until he expelled a considerable amount of
blood from his mouth and nose.
He then collapsed onto the ground next to
the pile of debris, dead.
An investigation following this incident found
that the guard had died after a sudden influx
of jagged metal and wood had teleported inside
of him, tearing his lungs apart from the inside
and causing the guard to die a painful and
horrific death.
Naturally, the site personnel were somewhat
concerned by this development.
They sent in a D-Class to investigate further,
but were surprised to find that the D-Class
in question was somehow completely fine.
The pile of debris that would soon be designated
SCP-1609 made no attempt to harm the D-Class
as it had the guard, and finding out why this
was the case came as a side effect of figuring
out exactly what had happened to SCP-1609.
Through a rigorous investigation, involving
more than one secret Foundation mole, they
discovered that SCP-1609 had previously been
in the possession of - you guessed it - the
Global Occult Coalition.
Back then, it was just the helpful chair you
once knew and loved, until the GOC had the
bright idea of forcing it into a woodchipper
in order to destroy it due to its connection
to someone called The Carpenter.
But all the GOC’s attempt actually succeeded
in doing was altering its form, and completely
changing its personality.
To put it in simple terms, SCP-1609 is now
a pile of possibly-sentient, teleporting wood
and metal chippings that suffers from a nasty
case of PTSD.
The incident with the wood chipper traumatized
SCP-1609, and its anxiety is triggered by
anything that reminds it of the GOC or the
wood chipper incident - this includes wearing
formal clothing, lab coats, protective clothing,
jumpsuits, and particularly body armor, but
also includes anyone carrying weapons, appearing
outwardly aggressive, using common GOC lingo,
or even mentioning the GOC in SCP-1609’s
proximity.
If any of this happens, it’s extremely likely
that SCP-1609 will resort to its only natural
defense mechanism, which is teleporting its
debris into the lungs of anyone it considers
to be a threat.
The guard had received this grisly punishment
because his clothes, weapon, and overall manner
caused SCP-1609 to regard him as a threat
and react accordingly.
You may think this is overkill on 1609’s
part, but if you were just trying to help
out the chairless people of the world and
someone fed you into a wood chipper, you’d
probably be a little jumpy too.
Since these early days, the Foundation has
learned to apply a more tender touch when
it comes to dealing with SCP-1609, and the
brilliant containment specialists even figured
out a way to keep 1609 happily contained…
by placing it in a flower bed inside its containment
chamber where its wood chips get to serve
as mulch for a variety of flowers and plants.
All attending researchers and guards dress
in plain clothes, and adopt a loose, pleasant
attitude while inside.
Whenever they’re around, they make a point
of saying how beautiful the flower bed is,
so that the disfigured anomaly that only ever
wanted to be helpful can still feel like it’s
doing something nice.
Because of these containment procedures, breaches
involving SCP-1609 have remained in the single
digits.
It’s a perfect example of less really being
more when it comes to containment.
The head researcher on the SCP-1609 case,
Dr. Sievert, released an internal document,
permanently affixed to the file like a kind
of cautionary signpost.
It’s a clear expression of exasperation
and rage at the actions of the Global Occult
Coalition, reading:
“SCP-1609 represents a perfect example of
the flaws inherent in the operating procedure
of the GOC, and serves as a cautionary tale
for any members of the Foundation who disagree
with our practices on containing dangerous
objects.
Prior to the Coalition getting their hands
on this, it was perfectly harmless.
A chair which teleports to you when you need
a seat is normal compared to most of the stuff
that we deal with on a regular basis.
When they put it through a woodchipper, it
got hurt, scared and angry, so it lashed out
at them.
By trying to 'protect the world' by destroying
it, they inadvertently made the situation
a whole lot worse.
SCP-1609 went from being harmless to deadly
in the space of a few minutes because of the
GOC, and we had to clean up the mess.
Thankfully, SCP-1609 is pretty simple for
us to deal with.
So long as we don't do anything stupid around
it, it won't fight back and it won't try to
leave.
Even if it does, it usually comes back.
I think I've worked out why.
It came to us because it was afraid of the
people who had hurt it.
That's why it always comes back.
It's afraid of the rest of the world now,
and it's looking to us for protection.
This is why we have Special Containment Procedures
instead of Special Destruction Procedures.
If you break something, it's broken forever.
When you try to destroy an anomaly, you can't
take back your mistakes.
That's what SCP-1609 has to tell us.
This is why we're right and the GOC is wrong,
people.”
But of course, there are two sides to every
story, and it’s important to understand
the GOC’s perspective on this whole mess.
To them, this has never been SCP-1609, it’s
KTE-0937-Velveteen, aka The Sixth Chair.
It was labeled as the “sixth” because
for the GOC, this chair was merely one part
of a wider investigation.
It belonged to a six piece furniture set created
by a dangerous, anomalous person of interest
named The Carpenter for a classified customer.
The GOC was able to intercept this deal, and
kill the Carpenter and his customer in the
process.
After that, all that was left was to eliminate
the anomalous objects and five of them were
incinerated without incident.
However, before they could do the same to
the Sixth Chair, they experienced an incinerator
malfunction.
Rather than waiting for the incinerator to
be fixed, a member of GOC personnel decided
to rush the job and run the chair through
the woodchipper.
It was at this point that its pieces first
lashed out, invading the lungs of this negligent
GOC member along with five others, killing
them all.
It was shortly after that that SCP-1609 manifested
in Foundation containment.
Much like Dr. Sievert did for the Foundation,
Assistant Director Kipling, one of the GOC’s
legion of middle managers, affixed a note
to the profile on KTE-0937-Velveteen that
reads:
“KTE-0937-Velveteen is an object lesson
in the importance of following proper operating
procedures.
Due to the lack of vigilance by the agent
on the scene, the object's threat level was
escalated, the object itself was not successfully
disposed of, and it has since fallen into
the hands of a hostile agency.
A single failure by a single operative resulted
in the deaths of six.
Remember this the next time you think about
cutting corners.”
And that’s a good lesson for everyone.
Whether you’re trying to destroy an anomalous
piece of furniture or keeping its remains
happy so that they don’t try to kill you,
cutting corners is always a fast track to
failure.
Now check out “SCP Global Occult Coalition
Explained” and “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation” for more dramatic
clashes between the Global Occult Coalition
and the SCP Foundation!